Hey! Bonus video today. But before it
begins, I just want to say I'm going to
be streaming tomorrow at twitch.tv/
netglow. It's gonna be.......probably the
best stream of your life.
Edgar - oh yeah *edgar scratching plop noise*
Oh, Edgar is
so excited for it as well. He might even be
there! It's going to be really fun we have
a ton of cool stuff we're gonna do.
Ah.....Just don't miss it, you don't want to
miss it. What are you doing?
Marzia - Don't miss it!
Thank you. Listen to Marzia.
Now enjoy the video.
what is happening family friendly
Felix here we're gonna play paradigma
paradigmmm
para.... paradigm haha
I played this game when it had the Kickstarter I loved
*burp from the deep pits within* I loved it I loved it a lot
I thought it was so interesting i've been
following the guys development on
twitter it's super interesting i'm very
excited to play it it doesn't happen
every day that I'm actually excited to
play the game that I'm playing how bow dat
ya choose your difficulty oh god how did
this happen I just ok I I think I'll go
with middle ok, ok, let's go, if I remember
correctly there should be a movie playing
*is your child a failure*
yes tekhhahaha *do you make it rain on a regular
basis* I do i do (loud song saying money money money?) *only to spend it on your
child's expensive taste in bullshit
coffee?* frappadick *is your child just an
asshole* yes, I mean my dog is :( *here at
DUPA genetics we have the solution. *Too bad*
prodigy child a fully customizable child
of your dreams the process is very
simple we gather your broken dreams we
combine it with our cutting-edge genetic
sequencing technology* okay *and finally
our secret sauce and then
your prodigy child is born* Greaaatttttt
child's success to chance* but what do I
do with the failure child *your prodigy child in
anything such as scientist, body builder* oh
wow *wizard, and CAT you know what
is it that you really want to risk the
embarrassment? Buy a prodigy child today
you won't regret it* honestly I'm calling
right now I can't oh god where did it go
wrong *time to put on some beatsies*
is he gonna put on beats
okay alright so here we are *ugh I'm so bored*
*aphsdasdfewg-_- Agh its the tumor talking to, the tumor is..
talking to me ok so here we are in
paradigm I like how he moves nice, we have
the John 300 3000 doesn't seem to be
working all right let's look at the
*one part if my* (dude got cut off) they are LPS we have
get rich or die of natural causes baby i
love you but i'm a t-rex okay Pluto if
only I was still (muffled by laugh - a planet) if you were a square
I'd love all your four sides that's
a bit too sexual for my taste alright we
have an adapter here *I could* that we
could pick up *this could be* *if only
people could adapt like this adapter
robot human marriage wouldn't be such a big issue
oh jeez I've forgotten how to use my
pockets again* (muffled large tutor mumbles nothing) really great tutorials
voice okay so if we have inventory
all right hey it's an adapter ah use
only John * I need some sort of the adapter
first* oh my god okay so we can do that
that's easy look how smart we are
aren't you feeling super smart hey how about
that I can solve puzzles on games i have
already played *aw mate what'd you unplug me for?*
the voice I expected bearded beats okay
all right talk to uhhhh I want to make
some fat beatsies
*Why isn't the computer booting?*
*I want to make some phat ass beatsies*
*Mate, with some of the filth I see in your internet history I'm not surprised.*
*Makes me contemplate if i want to be a part of this world.*
*Then I think about all the sheilas who would be gutted*
*and then I changed my mind.*
that face is so terrifying what is wrong
with it I don't know why it looks so-
he doesn't have a nose sorry I just realize
okay so we need to fuck all right this
might be a lil' tricky don't panic that
computer says derp on it why is your
cereal everywhere okay a floppy disk we
need a floppy disk there's whatever
let's uh let's pick it up wherever it is
let's pick it up I prefer to leave- full of
personal- okay we can't pick it up we
can't what assistant pick up
okay fine we'll just go to the red room
*UGHH* okay let's not go to the red room
I can't leave yet besides-
fuck okay we need that we need a floppy
disk all right why are there pants up here
those are my sexy pants for sexy- okay
forget I asked forget I asked okay
floppy disk maybe here I need to get
something
all right we have a da.. ohh its a diary
some kind of Russian maybe we need to
get one of these yeah it's got to be
this one pick up yesss
I'M SO SMART!!(we know pewds) how do we play it let's just let's uh
just give it to him here you go buddy
YEAH!! I told you
Haha what the hell is this option oh my
god this guy's Cringer than me I have no
idea what the.... haha
What the fuck? What is this?
Well you've really improved on your paper mache craft skills
how did he make that's the basic
gist of the sizzo if you don't get that floppy
you gotta get the floppy disc got it *pewds laughs*
One Day. But yeah go see Doug outside for
some directorydoos to- Okay we gotta see Doug
outside great let's go this is super fun
I'm really enjoying it Oh No meanwhile
oh god I think I'm convenient plot to
them yes the villain * you requested me sir?*
Yes I want, I want you to bring me paradigm
Is that Trump *you want to bring him back? yes we need we*
need you, are you alright sir?
I'm just going to let myself out.
oh alright sometimes I hate you fatty
father satiable urge for candy turned me
into this monstrosity but don't worry
your legacy will live on let it be that
is a beat that spits bead I remember
that at school actually related German
all of a sudden miniature unicorns
fighting warrior pugs why miniature
unicorns fighting flying folks power
station I mean by public bosses are
never a good idea or is it the best I
much what it's a cocktail hello
deactivated John 3000 good okay all
right let's start to the beach hey bro
zaffinos was a broom I dropped me that
fat BTW you mind dropping some set BTW
okay o Shaykh hey that's yeah I was
pretty good ah alright we need to know
about space cadet know much about these
biscuits all I know is that he is the
local drug addict godo quake near 47
years old uncomfortably aberrant fetish
for boxes I guess that's him and I don't
know much about him really except he
keeps asking for drugs in exchange for
his boxes also also blowjob hahahaha no
that's not family-friendly goddamn it uh
fine considered look away if I wasn't a
drug Ernest i would probably consider it
no no no not again fuck alright so we
got to find him a man right uh
I don't know how it look I leather metal
books yeah I guess I'll put this in my
industry wait wait what there was a mail
box oh fuck you saying else in the
second member lobo stop god damn it
there is another yeah there's a post
cousin here with a bottle of vodka
really shaky book go the only book is a
guarantee sixty percent of your daily
nutritional meal is it alcohol and the
fifty percent chance of unemployment
plus postcard map says to crystalis root
em for you second man you suck man okay
all right we're going there we're going
there excellent alright well looks like
we'll go there and the next episode if
you enjoyed watching leave it like even
if you want me to play more I would love
to do that so show your support and I
really appreciate this great way for me
to know whether you guys want more of
this or not and that's all for me for
now thank you so much for watching and
it's always stay awesome (bros/breast?)